all right so joe biden did an event
yesterday where he
spoke about donald trump's nomination of
amy coney barrett to the supreme court
to replace ruth bader ginsburg we
already looked at clips from
the nomination ceremony on saturday that
donald trump held at the white house
and at this event joe biden also took
questions from the media now as all of
you know
i don't agree with joe biden on every
policy or nearly every policy but in
some places i think joe biden has put
together some pretty reasonable
platforms which i would love to see
made a reality if he becomes president
but joe biden yesterday did something
really well
which is that he'd refused to play
donald trump's games and he refused to
play some of the games
that the media gets donald trump to play
but joe biden wasn't going to go for it
because joe biden was asked
in light of trump's supreme court
nominee and the nomination being so
hypocritical given that republicans in
2016 said oh we don't confirm justices
in the last year of a term
and now with 40 days to go they want to
confirm a supreme court justice
in light of that hypocrisy a question
that has come up
is whether joe biden will try to pack
the supreme court if he wins
should democrats try to pack the supreme
court
now packing the supreme court is
essentially expanding the court you add
justices so
if donald trump gets amy coney barrett
confirmed you would have a supreme court
that leans
six to three in the direction of
conservatives
joe biden could add four seats to the
supreme court
that would make it a 13 justice court
instead of nine
and he could appoint left-wing justices
to those four new seats
taking control of the court back making
it a 7-6
liberal majority now of course this is
hugely controversial
it's a major issue it is a non-starter
if joe biden doesn't win
and it doesn't happen in conjunction
with democrats taking the senate
but the great thing joe biden does
is he realizes that whether he says yes
or no
it's trouble and he's not going to play
the game with the reporter and he keeps
the focus on the now
take a look at how joe biden handled
this
he's almost no i have no comment
yes
that this nominee does get on the court
have you ruled out
expanding the supreme court as president
under any circumstances whatsoever
i am not and i i i know you're going to
be upset with my answer
but what i'm not going to do is play the
trump game
which is a good game he plays take
your eye off the issue before us
if i were to say yes or no to that that
becomes a big issue
that's the headline here i am focused on
one thing right now i really mean it
i'm focused on making sure the american
people understand
that they're being cut out of this
process they're entitled to be part of
and the cut out of design in order
to take away the aca and your health
care
in the midst of a pandemic that's the
focus
that's what it's on and that's the deal
thank you all so very very much
thank you so tomorrow we're going to
look at a clip of
dr jill biden handling a sort of
bogus direction during a cnn interview
but joe biden doing the right thing here
joe biden is correctly identifying that
you can't win
with that question if joe biden says yes
i will consider packing the court or i
will definitely try to pack the court
the right goes crazy and calls biden an
authoritarian and a fascist and all the
things that donald trump actually wants
to be
if joe biden says yes i will pack the
court
those on the left who think it's a bad
idea
that it's a divisive idea they will get
mad at joe biden
and if joe biden says no i won't
consider packing the court
those on the left who want him to pack
the court will say this
is why the dems lose they're weak they
give in
they won't ever do what they need to do
so joe biden correctly points out
right now donald trump is trying to get
amy coney barrett confirmed she wants to
get rid of the affordable care act
she's very much against roe v wade
period
that's the issue right now and this is
something that
i i guess we've become kind of
descensible or not decent we've we've i
am re-sensitized
to when an elected official properly
handles
a bad question or a poorly framed
question because
with the trump administration it's
either
trump's asked a question and he just
talks about something totally different
or trump is asked a question and he lies
but this is actually how you handle some
of these questions that have no possible
upside now earlier in the event joe
biden also made it very clear and i
think that this goes to
to to something that's astute that biden
and his campaign are doing right now
joe biden makes clear that what donald
trump is doing
on the supreme court is outrageous and
that at the core of it
is wanting to dismantle a lot of this
policy including the affordable care act
take a look
shortly before justice ginberg's passed
she uh she told her granddaughter and i
quote
my most fervent wish is that i will not
be replaced until a new president
is installed and a quote it wasn't a
personal request
it wasn't a favor being asked for
it was the last act of a long
unflinching career of standing
up for american democracy
never before in our nation's history has
the supreme court justice been nominated
and installed while a presidential
election
is already underway it defies
every precedent every expectation
of a nation where the people the people
are sovereign
and the rule of law reigns
but yesterday before justice ginsburg
could be laid to rest and after a
hundred thousands of americans
had already cast their ballots the
president nominated
a successor to her seat
it's no mystery about what's happening
here
president trump is trying to throw out
the affordable care act
he's been trying to do it for the last
four years
the republican party has been trying to
eliminate it
for a decade so i don't agree with biden
all the time on policy i certainly don't
agree with biden all the time on
strategy but i think that this is
logical keep the pressure on what they
are trying to do
right now rather than the hypotheticals
if joe biden wins there's
more than enough time for those
hypotheticals and when the hypotheticals
might ingratiate you with some but
alienate others there's very little
upside to going in that direction what
joe biden is trying to do here
is to cement in the minds of the voters
the stakes that are at play
and that hopefully i'm hoping he will do
that tomorrow night during the first
presidential debate tomorrow
tuesday we will be starting live
coverage of the first
presidential debate between donald trump
and joseph r biden jr
8 30 p.m eastern time 5 30 pm pacific
we will be live on youtube live on
twitch and live on facebook i hope you
will join me
this is precisely the correct messaging
from joe biden and
by the way as a now we're getting into
just real
nitty gritty policy i still don't
understand how repealing or gutting the
affordable care act
without a real replacement plan which
trump doesn't have
days before an election i don't even get
how that's a winning strategy for
donald trump that's another story
altogether but they are again talking
about
how quickly can we get rid of the
affordable care act days before an
election with no plan to replace it
you're going to try to get rid of it i
don't see how that's winning electoral
strategy
but donald trump did win in 2016 so
maybe he knows something i don't